time flies when you're running for your
life please Jen Daisy there were more
only Daisy I took a long time
you got the nor dae bak sheep run it all
on your own yep well god damn my hat
goes off Mike Bochy re senior producer
aren't involved what's up man Wow
nothing much how's it going with you
Chris dude it's good i just got to play
some evolved uh alphas coming up I
didn't we didn't do well we lost the
monster I think you gave a great effort
one of them was you so yes myself on the
back well that's why they call me coach
iary instead of Oh cheering if all four
human trappers trying to wrangle one
human-controlled monster it's pretty
gnarly you keep coming back for more and
I love playing with you it's awesome
it's really fun I've had some success as
a monster but it's also really stressing
cuz like here here this high-powered
dude and I totally like to eat some guys
up but when their sports eat them up
teaming up on you using all their unique
abilities it gets through it's super
stressful as the monster there's sort of
a Zen state that you have to achieve
which is knowing that you're this
powerful player controlled beast with
all these special abilities as long as
you kind of play it cool you know be
aware of your surroundings you'll be
able to own the knowledge be the hunter
yourself aw it's big office coming up
more people are gonna get to transplant
exactly that's really the point of our
big alpha we want to go as big as we can
with this early look at evolve we've got
all of the hunters all of the monsters
and all of the maps that we've shown to
date and then on top of that we've got
some cool new stuff that were to be
showing you the way of progression maybe
we'll talk a little bit about that love
to and as well as some additional bells
and whistles so yeah we're super excited
about it's coming up this October
thirtieth for exclusive for Xbox one and
then from the 31st to the second for pc
and please
or as well so do you think it's
important for you guys to get this out
to folks because of all this kind of a
different beast pardon my terrible if
it's fun because it's you know for v1
you know anytime you talk to anyone
about involved that's that's what here
but it is kind of a different experience
when you play it you know there's
competitive aspects there's cooperative
aspects and there's also just the solo
experience of being a monster vs. you
know from third person view versus the
first person view of a hunter there's
there's a lot of different sort of
player experience there absolutely and
that I think really is testament to the
reason why evolves done so well when
we've shown it at e3 and games come you
know we won best of show at both of
those and that's I you know we're the
first game apparently in history to have
won both those in the same year and I
think that speaks a lot to the fact that
evolve is offering something unique to
players the chance to go solo be the
monster be the boss battle as the
monster or experience the rich
cooperative play that was at the heart
of great titles like left for dead that
the team at Turtle Rock Studios is
bringing to evolve and pairing with this
kind of monstrous first-person play a
single player experience and you know
it's that unique experience that nearly
i think is what players have always been
looking for when it comes to
experiencing awesome titles on xbox one
on a Playstation and rnc now having
played myself there's definitely sort of
the thrill of victory the agony of
defeat you want to tell the story
match at the end of every match but then
you know playing it in the environments
we played it and we haven't really
delved into and you guys haven't really
sort of laid out to the extent that you
are with big alpha for the progression
system that's right so talk to us a
little bit about how that's going to
work in the big alpha power players even
on that you know four-day weekend that
they are presumably canceling all their
plans to just play evolve how's the
progression going to work so yes we are
giving players a first taste an early
taste of what is the sword full
progression experience for evolved so
taking all of the hunters monsters and
maps that we've shown to date we're
letting players start out with the
hunter teams that they would get in the
game when it launches and pair that with
the initial monster which is Goliath and
then as they play through rounds using
the different abilities they're going to
accomplish feats gain emblems and
mastery so that I like healing your
teammates a lot or getting some getting
a head shot on the exact or getting an
orbital strike in there exactly so doing
doing heavy damage with an orbital
strike might be a special feat for Hank
right so then Hank gains his mastery not
only for orbital strike but then he
gains an overall feat via his end gains
and emblem for having accomplished that
and that builds his that person that
players ranked so the rank is then used
to match you with other players of like
rank and then the mastery is used to
unlock new weapon upgrades as well as
additional hunters so when you've done
all of the use all of paints various
abilities is orbital strike
you can then unlock the next hunter in
that class which is bucket very
different support characters we play so
within the within the big alpha you'll
have to lay with the one of the first
four hunters and then you'll unlock the
rest of hunters yes you also be able to
unlock look correct that's right that's
right so playing playing with Goliath
using that rocks his rock smash his
bleep smash his rock throw his charge
inspire breath appropriately over time
you're going to get to unlock Kraken who
plays very differently you know he's got
his air burst abilities his powerful
dark energy attacks as lightning strike
his vortex glass and aftershock and then
you can start mixing and matching you
know once you've unlocked those
characters you can not only switch
between the different classes so you
have a different experience on either
the hunter side or the monster side but
then you get to switch within each class
which of those characters you want to
play and then of course we're offering a
selection of different maps so that's
going to change things up over time and
then you know this is only kind of what
we're showing right now and then over
time we're going to be adding even more
on top of it as more maps more hunters
we've got we still have the last set of
hunters who we want to reveal to you
guys last monster as my letter is money
keeping very title of the love and um
but you know but I we think that getting
an experience getting experiencing the
big alpha we hope that everybody feels
like you do afterwards just one more
well here's hoping man and also this the
first time we've seen the game up and
running on an xbox one that's right so
this footage that you guys that we're
looking at right now is xbox one it is
looking and playing really well as you
can see we've got some great matches
going and yeah this is uh this is
console gaming at its best alright big
alpha it's coming Thursday the 30th xbox
one exclusive to Xbox one for 24 hours
then friday through sunday will
to be on pc and ps4 that's right and you
can I think you guys are giving away
some special code will be given away
codes awesome really excited for that
and then we've also check this out
involve gamecom and our Twitter and our
Facebook pages and we will I've got
other opportunities to get people in as
well all right thanks a lot like awesome
thanks Chris me off
Oh